Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi's
BJP has declared victory in the
country's election while vote counting
is not yet aware BJP supporters have
started celebrating after a first tally
showed the Hindu nationalist with a
decisive lead over their nearest rivals
the Indian National Congress Rahul
Gandhi president of the Congress party
has lost his own parliament seat which
his family has held almost continuously
for the last four decades the poll is
widely being viewed as a referendum on
Modi's leadership he's on course to
extend the commanding majority he won
back in 2014
joining me now from Delhi I have on the
line DW is an image as well
Nisha Modi has already claimed victory
what has he been saying Mohammed ah he
has appreciated what the warders have
delivered what the National mandate has
been he has put out of youth week
actually saying that this is a victory
for the country that is both actually
mean that the country supports the BJP
effort against cronyism corruption
communalism even and Sufism and all
across New Delhi already outside the BJP
headquarters we are actually seeing
massive posters going up with pictures
of merkins and Modi's saying thanking
voters for their blessing thanking
borders for the mandate and saying this
was the time for new India that's the
message the BJP has been putting out
also that is Modi and all of the leaders
saying they have been humbled by the
spices which year which looks to be
bigger than the one record in 2014 and
let me share what about the opposition
Congress party now we know that Rahul
Gandhi has lost his family seat in
Amethi but how the party is standing in
the election as a whole well um it looks
like unfortunately for the Congress it
has not fared much better dan is is the
last time around now the pasta itself
held about what you both need the
expectation from fans right now the
thing
it pleased that out is by another 10
feet and it's even been called into
question if they have enough beach chair
who form the opposition he need the
opposition the other important part is
to watch for the regional bodies which
were potentially going to form a
coalition with the Congress but even
they have not performed as well as they
would have thought you and the
non-aligned party that they are called
which are not in the future because all
the congressmen have also not been able
to they came because all the room in the
Parliament the people in the parliament
has been taken up by the BJP and
therefore what she'll actually is a well
about 50% to the opposition it is
basically even though the results are
not completely out the opposition has
been decimated so then we shall when
will we have a final official results to
these elections we have been watching
trends coming all of course as all the
counting happens in several grounds in
all the constituencies of India but
already some victories like the one we
mentioned Tommy Gandhi's losing his
family's resolve beef some of those wins
have already started coming in the
Election Commission has been posting
official results unity Commission's
across the body given the charge of
holding these elections but in a few
hours we should expect the results by it
by late evening India time also of
course the verification of the
electronic voting machines we will be
done later this evening but given that
the BJP has declared victory and given
that the Congress has in some way access
to defeat it was unlikely that for the
delays of the results are going to
happen by this evening we will know for
sure what the country actually already
knows for sure
Prime Minister Narendra Modi a lot fiber
suggest well in Delhi thank you very
much for that